Damonte KZ just got fined well not even
fined just lost money and just got
suspended for the rest of the season for
making a legal hit what is that man
supposed to do his head did not hit he
put his shoulder into mik uh Michael
pitman's chest and he just got suspended
for the rest of the year for a throw
that Garner menu make he's trying to
make a flying catch is a player just
supposed to let another player catch the
ball what is the point of playing
defense any more in NFL if you cannot
make hits I did not think that was a bad
hit I did not think it was a dirty hit
he made a play where he thought he could
and it's unfortunate Michael Pitman got
hurt that's completely unfortunate but
as Tom Brady said and people after the
people again they are making almost some
possible to play defense in NFL I mean
you look at the play with jron kurur
when on that second and the player drops
the ball he doesn't put his head down
his shoulder doesn't go in he comes on
top of the player after he drops the
ball and it gets a unnecessary roughness
it's just like how can you play football
in the NFL right now it's almost
completely like we're in a sport where
they make it so hard to play defense and
so easy to play offense you see Josh
Allen he's 66 240 people call him a
running back he could flop and get a
defensive uh a a rough iner passer it's
just like what are you supposed to do
with some of this stuff and I mean the
late slides the time up they they they
they run all the way into the point
you're about to contact them in the
slide there needs to be a gap in between
the slides I mean they make it so hard
and then sometimes they don't even slide
they just keep running when you think
they're going to slide they make it so
hard to play defense and it's across the
league it's across the league and it's
and it's obvious it's obvious but yet I
see time and time again you could be
rushing a tackle and a chipper could
come Blindside hit you you but let you
do that to an offensive player or you
return a touchdown and it's illegal it's
just like where is the space for defense
where is the space where is there going
to be breathing room I mean it and and
and it's terrible right now it's
honestly terrible I think the NFL needs
to make adjustments they need to make um
they need to make like it's almost like
football is turning into basketball
right football is supposed to be some
phys a physical sport where it's man on
man and at the end of the day it's
supposed to go
into you know whatever happens happens
right if you can't handle the sport
don't play it right our viewership don't
want to see flags for flops and things
like like this isn't basketball I'm not
calling basketball players you know
anything but they do a lot of fake
charges
flopping I see so many people act like
they got hit in the face and stuff like
that I mean obviously I can't go into no
direct league with these players cuz
they'll call foul for almost everything
like it's just it's almost it's like
embarrassing the sport and I know maybe
that's why oldheads in the league say
man I couldn't play in these times I
couldn't do this in these times and it's
understandable they're changing the game
where it's just such a offensive League
where you just can't do anything I
mean anything but that that's my piece
on it I mean if they change it they
change it if they don't I don't we just
got to play and just keep keep doing
what we're trying to do and that's just
contain these great players and just
can't hit them you just you can do
everything in football but can't hit
them I think football will be flag
football in about 5 10 years I mean
honestly we're we're penalizing and
taking money from people's families for
playing the way the game should be
played you know I think if anything
people like Ryan Clark Troy palalo Ray
Lewis these great players who we who we
loved for the way they played the game
if they played in today's day they might
be kicked out of the league like is that
like is that not insane like the Ronnie
Lots the Ed Reads like the people the
Shawn Taylor why did people love Shawn
Taylor because of his energy how he he
loved the game he used to come down and
kill people kill people but yet now we
we're we're we're we're basically saying
we don't want that anymore we don't want
those great players that we constantly
talk about the the the people that we
love the people that we put in the Hall
of Fame and we cherish we don't want
them people to be those guys no more we
don't want that we want this new era of
BS that we're calling it it's New Era
this new era is crazy the people that we
and it's almost like you got to be
mindful of trying to hit a player or
touch a player because you don't want to
get fine you don't want and like you see
players coming off on could be sacks
because they're pumping the ball and you
don't want to hit a quarterback late you
don't want to cost your team it it's
just ridiculous